hundreds of people protested in the
coastal city of daiwei
in myanmar as demonstrations continued
in parts of the country
against the february coup and the
junta's increasingly brutal crackdown
the demonstrations came as eu foreign
ministers in brussels
announced sanctions on 11 military
officials in myanmar
linked to the coup and ongoing violence
in the country
among them junta leader menon klein
all direct financial support from our
development system to the government's
reform programs
is withheld some rights campaigners said
the impact to the sanctions would be
limited
it cannot make a difference for simple
reasons that
the you know 11 or so generals and
individuals that have been that
single out for targeted sanctions
um they keep their assets in places like
china or
singapore banks and you know in
southeast asia
and you know so therefore if we
really want uh to have any impact
on the military and its behavior the
eu should seriously look at you know
de-recognize military attaches across as
european union countries the sanctions
against the military officials in
myanmar clearly won't be enough to end
the violence
but after weeks of only condemning the
coup and calling for democracy
the eu's decision to finally act sends a
powerful message
natasha butler al-jazeera paris